baltimore ist eine der gefährlichsten
städte in den usa
officer männer wurde gerade zu einem
einsatz gerufen
denn unterwegs
er arbeitet für das drogen dezernat die
beamten haben einen verdächtigen auf der
route zwischen bord timo und washington
dc angehalten
[Musik]
wir überprüfen ihn erstmal
sie vermuten dass er einen drogendealer
ist aber sie brauchen beweise
haben sie was bei sich
[Musik]
officer männer durchsucht das auto des
verdächtigen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich vermute mal dass ihr was drin war
das tütchen wurde aufgerissen und das
zeug versteckt manchmal ist es schwierig
das lag direkt hier drunter
kleine mengen können überall im wagen
seien
kurz darauf finden die beamten eine tüte
mit drogen die menge könnte den man für
zehn jahre ins gefängnis bringen
müssen heroin und fentanyl denn fentanyl
ist viel stärker
in der innenstadt von baltimore würde
man für diese menge so etwa 3000 dollar
zahlen mindestens
[Musik]
der kommt wegen besitzes und
verkaufsabsicht vor gericht
in deutschland wurde der junge mann nun
auf der wache verhört in anwesenheit
eines rechtsbeistands hier kommt der
direkt in haft
[Musik]
die stadt frederik hat sich ihr neues
gefängnis mehr als sechs millionen
dollar kosten lassen es ist eines der
modernsten der usa alles hier läuft über
computer hier lang
der neuankömmling ist nun einer von
vielen gefängnisinsassen in ganz
maryland sind es rund
36.000
auf die gesamtbevölkerung bezogen sind
das zehn mal so viele gefangene wie in
deutschland
hier lautet die aktuelle devise null
toleranz
baltimore die größte stadt des us
bundesstaats ist die stadt mit den
meisten
tötungsdelikten in den ganzen usa
[Musik]
er bewegt sich ich brauche deckung
seit der amtszeit des ehemaligen us
präsidenten donald trump ist maryland
stramm republikanisch sehr viele
festnahmen fälle von polizeibrutalität
extreme urteile
direkt 20 jahren für eine schlägerei ich
war total am boden und fassungslos
dieser mann verkörpert diesen extremen
ansatz
[Musik]
sheriff chuck denkens ein hardcore
konservativer er sieht sich als soldat
im krieg gegen die kriminellen
ich sehe das wie ein gladiator
ich habe meinen gegner in die arena und
töte ihn
auch im gefängnis herrscht eine
null-toleranz-politik
nächste leute drin bitte
auch gang boss plate wird hier in seine
schranken verwiesen
wir drin wirst du mental gebrochen ein
strenges regiment gegen das ist schon
aufstände gab
zwar auch manchmal verstecken sie messer
hier im buch rücken
die wächter müssen ständig auf der hut
sein
stellen sie das buch da wieder hin ein
gefangener im staatsgefängnis deshalb
soll ein wächter getötet haben
dies sind die härtesten gefängnisse in
den vereinigten staaten
sie benutzten plexiglas weil man das
durch den metalldetektor kriegt
ein einblick in die gefängnisse von
maryland
die sheriffs denken sie hätten die
kontrolle aber da liegen sie falsch von
wegen
[Musik]
frederik county pressen
dem hochsicherheitsgefängnis bewährt mit
natodraht sieht man maryland null
toleranz politik schon von außen an
[Musik]
fenster gibt es hier kaum dafür umso
mehr kameras sie verfolgen jeden schritt
der gefangenen
die gelbe linie dürfen sie unter keinen
umständen übertreten
auch für die gefängniskleidung gibt es
strenge vorschriften
die insassen tragen gestreifte uniformen
wie es vor langer zeit üblich war
[Musik]
er verantwortete strenge regiment chuck
jenkins stolzer sheriff und leiter des
gefängnisses
[Musik]
jeder der reinkommt wird nach verbotenen
gegenständen und waffen durchsucht
jeden montagmorgen macht jenkins seinen
kontrollgang durch das gefängnis
hey leute alles klar gab es festnahmen
wir haben rund 325 gefangenen hier wie
viele kommen am tag
unterschiedlich heute waren es drei wenn
viel los ist können es auch mal zehn
oder zwölf sein
um immer den überblick über alle
insassen zu haben hat er scharf eine
halbe million dollar in ein hochmodernes
management system investiert
das ist so ähnlich wie die anzeigetafeln
am flughafen wo man landen de und
abfliegende flüge sehen kann das system
zeigt uns den status der gefangenen
ihren aktuellen aufenthaltsort und wohin
sie als nächstes gehen man sieht ob sie
gerade in ihrer zelle sind und wer sich
wo im gebäude bewegt jetzt hat sich die
anzeige gerade aktualisiert wofür steht
gelb für die wäscherei okay
gelb für die wäscherei rot für die küche
grün für besucher und weiß wenn sie in
ihrer zelle sind die wächter sehen auf
einen blick wer wo ist die gefangenen
müssen ständig eine karte bei sich
tragen die an jeder tür gescannt wird
nicht während meiner amtszeit der letzte
ausbruch war
1992 oder 94er 92 seit 30 jahren ist
hier kein gefangener mehr ausgebrochen
der chef sieht das als seinen
persönlichen verdienst anders als in
anderen gefängnissen sind die insassen
hier nicht in einem großen gebäude
untergebracht in dem sie einander
begegnen hier gibt es einzelne blogs mit
jeweils nur zehn zellen so können sie
kaum etwas schmuggeln es ist wie ein
gefängnis im gefängnis leute bitte seit
etwas leiser solange wir da sind
große speisesäle gibt es hier nicht die
mahlzeiten werden direkt in den zellen
serviert so sollen schlägereien
verhindert werden
einige gefangene haben versucht sich für
jemand anderen auszugeben seitdem werden
dreimal täglich die ausweise geprüft
[Musik]
ich prüfe bei jedem gefangenen den
ausweis und hage seinen namen auf der
liste ab dann händigen wir ihnen das
tablett aus wenn es irgendwelche
veränderungen im blog gibt
drei mal täglich jeden tag ohne ausnahme
alles um immer die perfekte kontrolle zu
haben
mehrmals pro woche untersuchen die
wächter jede zelle im
hochsicherheitstrakt
sie inspizieren alle persönlichen
gegenstände
auch die kleidung
manchmal haben die gefangenen vier oder
fünf hosen obwohl sie nur drei haben
dürfen
die erlaubte höchste anzahl an solchen
paaren liegt bei 7
das ist blakes zelle er ist 33 jahre alt
und hat ein jahrzehnt seines lebens
hinter gittern verbracht er guckt nach
ob nach der durchsuchung noch alle fotos
da sind auch die die diskret über seinem
bett hängen
[Musik]
die darf man nicht sehen sonst werden
sie uns weggenommen und wir kriegen sie
nicht zurück
blake ist kein unschuldslamm er wurde
2009 wegen bewaffneten raubes verurteilt
er sitzt im hochsicherheitstrakt ein
weil er zur black guerilla family gehört
die afro-amerikanische gang gehört zu
den mächtigsten der usa ihre kriminellen
aktivitäten reichen von zuhälterei über
drogenhandel bis hin zu entführungen sie
ist auf der straße und im gefängnis
berüchtigt
diese aufnahmen einer überwachungskamera
sind schon einige jahre alt
sie zeigen wie gangmitglieder mitglieder
einer rivalisierenden bande angreifen
solche schlägereien zwischen gangs sind
oft extrem brutal
[Musik]
break ist einer der anführer seiner gang
er darf absolut nichts in seiner zelle
haben das als waffe dienen könnte
als stifter haben wir nur solche flexi
stifter damit kann man keinen verletzten
weil sie einfach nachgeben
statt richtiger zahnbürsten haben wir so
many dinge
daraus lässt sich keine waffe machen
und ich kann hier nicht in einen anderen
block gehen was wird sonst als
ausbruchsversuch bewertet
[Musik]
wenn sie dich mental brechen dann war's
das und das passiert oft
hier ist auch keine musik für viele von
uns war musik unser leben wichtig für
unsere beziehungen zu anderen menschen
und um mit bestimmten situationen
klarzukommen und
hier dürfen wir keine musik hören das
geht doch nicht wir bitten immer wieder
darum aber sie sagen nein
nicht einmal musik hören zu können für
break ist dass rassismus
er nutzt sein interview um seine meinung
über sheriff denkens zu sagen
[Musik]
ich hasse ihn
ich hasse das gefängnis und die sheriffs
und sie hassen uns
das sind rassisten hier läuft das so
wenn du mit einer waffe und drogen
erwischt wirst du bist schwarz ist in
den knast bist du weiß stecken sie dich
in einen drogen programm
scherf denkens ist eine lokale
berühmtheit und er ist beliebt in
maryland für seine null toleranz politik
wird er seit zwölf jahren als chef
wiedergewählt
und jenkins hat seine vorbilder
das ist ein foto von russell crowe
gladiator ich liebe den film denn ich
denke auch wie ein gladiator
ich ziehe meinen gegner in die arena und
töte ihn
so gewinne ich auch weil ich gehe in die
arena und komme als sieger heraus
ich mag harte kämpfe im film ist er
ähnlich wie ich ruhig und hart
zu diesem bild hier gibt es eine
geschichte das bin ich im alter von zwei
jahren
unser chef hat jenkins wusste schon vor
50 jahren dass er chef werden will für
mich ist dieser posten das wohl
ehrenhafte sste was ich je hätte machen
können
der scharf ist stolz darauf republikaner
zu sein und er war ein glühender
anhänger von donald trump und dessen
repressive politik
im februar 2018 war er sogar ins weiße
haus eingeladen gemeinsam mit anderen
republikanischen
[Musik]
land war donald trumps wahlkampf
besonders erfolgreich nach 15 jahren
demokratischer mehrheiten wählte der
kleine bundesstaat zum ersten mal wieder
die republikaner die gründe armut
verwahrlosung
drogenabhängigkeit und kriminalität die
mit abstand meisten menschen in maryland
leben in der großstadt baltimore und
hier geht es seit jahrzehnten bergab
früher einmal hatte die stadt floriert
dank ihres hafens inzwischen wird sie
immer ärmer und ärmer
die kriminalität treibt die menschen aus
dem stadtzentrum
die todesstrafe hat maryland 2013
abgeschafft aber die anzahl der zu
lebenslänglichen haftstrafen
verurteilten ist enorm hoch und all die
menschen müssen untergebracht werden
[Musik]
wenige kilometer außerhalb von baltimore
liegt das jazzit state prison
es unterschied nicht dem sheriff
besondern den gouverneur von maryland
3600 gefangenen leben hier mörder räuber
vergewaltiger
sie alle sitzen lange haftstrafen ab und
sie werden streng bewacht
[Musik]
cornish hier wir gehen jetzt den hof ab
cornish arbeitet seit fünf jahren als
wachbeamten in jazz ab jeden morgen
überprüft sie den hof bevor die
gefangenen hinaus dürfen
ein arbeiter könnte hier einen handschuh
mit drogen drin versteckt haben es
könnten waffen versteckt sein
manchmal werden dinge auf den fenstern
heraus gereicht angefangene die hier
draußen im hof sind
auch hinter gittern gibt es kriminalität
cornish kontrollrunde wird von einem
funkspruch unterbrochen
es gibt ein problem im gebäude
[Musik]
irgendetwas ist passiert die beamten
müssen die situation klären darum werden
der hof und der trainingsraum gesperrt
so dass sie sich darauf konzentrieren
können
auf dem gang kam es zu einer schlägerei
in solchen fällen greift das notfall
protokoll alle gefangenen müssen sofort
in ihre zellen
aber einige weigern sich
[Musik]
zurück in die zelle ja ich bin doch
schon auf dem weg
für heute ist der hofgang gestrichen
eine der größten sorgen der beamten ist
das ein aufstand ausbricht in us
gefängnissen kommt das immer wieder vor
und oft sind solche aufstände extrem
gewalttätig meist beginnen sie als
schlägereien zwischen rivalisierenden
gangs die dann ausufern teilweise mit
tödlichem ende
[Musik]
ein 43 jähriger gefangener wurde
erstochen
die polizei ermittelt im
hochsicherheitsgefängnis von jsf in den
letzten vier jahren wurden im gefängnis
von jsf drei gefangene getötet
daher nimmt der anstaltsleiter die
heutige auseinandersetzung sehr ernst er
hat eine außerplanmäßige zellen
inspektion angeordnet
rasdorf euch selbst und aufeinander auf
wenn was passiert sieht euch zurück
beobachtet die lage und ruft verstärkung
wir kommen dann und unterstützen reich
verteilt euch im gang und lasst euch
nicht in die ecke drängen
auf geht's
weibliche beamte vor ort
cornish und ihre kollegin machen auf
ihre anwesenheit im blog der männer
aufmerksam
hierüber
der blog den sie inspizieren hat 20
zellen mit insgesamt 40 gefangenen gut
einfach stehen bleiben
die männer sind nicht gerade begeistert
von der überraschungs durchsuchung
[Musik]
manchmal verstecken sie messer im
buchrücken
stellen sie das buch
im gefängnis gibt es überall gewalt aber
ich bin überzeugt dass die beamten hier
alles tun um die kontrolle zu behalten
man kann sich schon relativ sicher
fühlen hier läuft ja nicht jeder mit
einem messer durch die gegend
die wächter konfiszieren praktisch
täglich waffen sie werden hier in diesem
verwaltungsbüro verwahrt außer
reichweite der gefangenen
das ist ein stück metall aus dem eine
stichwaffe gebastelt wurde
das alles sind von gefangenen
hergestellte waffen
die hier bestehen aus leuchtkörpern aus
den blogs
wenn man sowas an ein gangmitglied oder
andere interessenten verkauft kriegt man
für die um die 50 für die sogar 100
dollar wenn wir dieser waffe hier kann
man jemanden töten
um den handel mit diesen waffen zu
unterbinden hat die gefängnisleitung
einen metalldetektor installiert
manche gefangene tricksen ihn aus indem
sie messer aus glas oder sogar plastik
fertigen
sie sind clever sie benutzten plexiglas
weil der der metalldetektor nicht
anschlägt
manche der waffen haben wir direkt am
mann gefunden in der tasche der hose im
mantel oder im rektum
allen wachbeamten hier ist schmerzlich
bewusst dass einer ihrer kollegen mit
einer solchen waffe ermordet wurde
[Musik]
david makin starb 2006 im alter von 42
jahren 2
gefangenen hatten bei seinem abend
kontrollgang zehnmal auf ihn
eingestochen
[Musik]
es sind weder die wächter noch die
gefangenen völlig sicher
das gilt auch für den frauen trakt die
43 jährige natascha ist besorgt
ich kann sie nicht finden
samoa ist ihre tochter
ich kann schon mal nirgends finden
beide sitzen seit zwölf jahren im selben
gefängnis ein
entschuldigung ist für mich schon runter
gekommen
haben sie schon mal gesehen
das ist das einzige frauengefängnis in
maryland hier sitzen schwerkriminelle
mit gewöhnlichen gefangenen an einem
tisch manchmal eskaliert die lage
[Musik]
niemand will mit einer massen mörderin
oder so im selben raum sein
man muss alle im blick haben man weiß
nie wo für die sitzung
gestern erst geriet wieder ein streit
außer kontrolle eine gefangene musste
danach im krankenhaus behandelt werden
ich warte sechs stunden auf dich
janeiro hat sich nun länger als üblich
mit einer mitgefangenen unterhalten
dachte durchkommen nicht mehr du hättest
längst hier sein sollen ich bin es
gewohnt mich abzuholen oder dass du
schon da bist
natascha und schimmel mutter und tochter
eine eher ungewöhnliche konstellation im
gefängnis die frauen haben einem mann
die beine gebrochen natascha wurde zu 28
jahren haft verurteilt zu 20
im november 2007 wurden mehrere
jugendliche die den 44-jährigen
alles begann mit einem streit zwischen
einem nachbarn und einem ihrer cousins
die auseinandersetzung eskalierte
schließlich waren mehrere dutzend
personen beteiligt darunter chanel und
ihre mutter sie gingen auf einen der
männer auf der gegnerischen seite los
und verletzten ihn schwer
er wird für den rest seines lebens
behindert sein
wir danken dir für dieses essen segne
jene die weniger glück haben nahmen sie
so armen
zwölf jahre später sitzen der tasche und
ihre tochter noch immer für diesen
gewaltakt in haft schamel war erst 16
als sie ins gefängnis kam sie ist hier
erwachsen geworden
ich passe auf meine tochter auf es gibt
ja eine menge fehlgeleiteter kids die
kommen hier haben keinen der auf sie
aufpasst machen dummes zeug drogen dazu
hat sie keine gelegenheit ich stocke sie
praktisch
trotzdem ist es gefährlich denn manchen
hier ist einfach alles egal
letztens gab es eine schlägerei nach der
beide ins krankenhaus mussten
keiner hat auf die andere eingestochen
und die hat sie wurde mit einem schloss
oder sowas geschlagen
das sind nicht die üblichen rumzicken
hier wollen sie dich ernsthaft verletzen
die situation ist übel aber es ist ein
trost für sie das hier ist und es mit
mir durchzustehen so dass ich nicht
allein bin
dass ich mitgehen für sie sie mag
joghurt
ich verstecke gmbh
gefangene dürfen kein essen aus dem
speisesaal mitnehmen aber der tasche hat
gewisse inoffizielle privilegien weil
sie sich in den letzten zwölf jahren
vorbildlich geführt hat die wächterinnen
lassen ihr etwas mehr durchgehend als
anderen
läuft eine tasche hat sogar die
erlaubnis ihre zelle nach eigenem
geschmack zu dekorieren
eindeutig die schickste zelle im ganzen
gefängnis
acht quadratmeter die sie sich mit ihrer
mit insassen teilt
[Musik]
keine andere zelle sieht so aus wie
meine
dass hier habe ich selbst gemacht um
etwas viel rein zu bringen
dieses bild hat eine freundin für mich
gemalt das habe ich aufgehängt
im gefängnis ist es schwierig es sich
gemütlich zu machen
wenn man die zelle hübsch dekoriert und
schönen farben
das hilft ja man fühlt sich besser
ein weiteres trostpflaster ihrem make-up
tasche es ist nicht viel aber hier
drinnen sind lidschatten und lippenstift
so wertvoll wie gold
das habe ich seit vier jahren
seit vier jahren kommen wir nicht mehr
ein neues make up
also muss man aufheben was man hat 6
track
ich finde ich als frau fühlen und nicht
sonst wie rumlaufen ich kümmere mich um
ein haar trage lippenstift
habe ich in einer zeitschrift gesehen
ihren größten schatz versteckt natascha
unter dem bett mit der erlaubnis der
wachbeamten
ich bin schon so lange hier ich habe
nicht mehr viel zeug von früher
ich habe ein neues album für sie gemacht
bin ich mit ihr als baby
sieht sie aus wie ich damals oder
dieses geheime album soll am tag ihrer
entlassung bekommen erinnerungen an eine
schöne zeit vor der haft
[Musik]
das macht mich ganz traurig dass sie all
das nicht hat
sie soll fotos von sich haben
das ist kein schönes bild von ihr sie
hasste es aber ich liebe es um man
deswegen trägt man bei sowas besser kein
make-up
hätten sie die selbe straftat in
deutschland begangen während natascha
und ihre tochter schon längst wieder
frei
aber nicht in maryland
ich habe 25 jahre für die
körperverletzung und drei jahre wegen
einer waffe bekommen also 28 weil ich
vorbestraft war
aber dass sie direkt 20 jahre für eine
schlägerei bekommen hat
ich war entsetzt und völlig fassungslos
das war ein sehr hartes urteil
ich weiß dass man hart gegen manche
kriminelle vorgehen muss aber das kann
man doch nicht einfach auf alle anwenden
wo ich aufgewachsen bin gibt es ständig
stress man prügelt sich hat eine große
klappe und lässt sich nichts gefallen
du hast meine schwester eine ich hau dir
eine du fast meinen kleinen bruder anton
ich knall die eine so alt aber
eine tasche und ihre tochter sehen licht
am ende des tunnels sie haben hoffnung
[Musik]
sie haben um vorzeitige entlassung
ersucht
statistisch liegen ihre chancen bei eins
zu drei
[Musik]
das justizsystem in maryland ist eines
der strengsten der usa dennoch hat die
kriminalität nicht abgenommen außerdem
frederik county im zuständigkeitsbereich
des berühmten sheriffs jenkins hier
präsentiert er seine neueste
errungenschaft halb auto halb panzer
kugelsicheren scheiben stahlplatten an
den seiten das fahrzeug hält einer
granate stand es wird sogar von der
us-armee in kriegsgebieten eingesetzt
ja mal los aber wie so ein
militärfahrzeug die kriminalitätsrate
senken
so zeigen wir der öffentlichkeit dass
wir ausgerüstet sind um sie zu schützen
dass wir eine starke behörde sind und
unser möglichstes tun um die bevölkerung
wirkungsvoll zu schützen
finden sie das nicht etwas übertrieben
nicht heutzutage
wenn man sich mal den anschlag auf den
nachtclub in orlando florida vor ein
paar jahren ansieht oder den
terroranschlag in san bernardino
kalifornien sie wurden beide durch den
einsatz so eines fahrzeugs beendet
der sheriff ist davon überzeugt dass das
fahrzeug auch zur bekämpfung des
drogenhandels beitragen kann die sagen
wir wollen nicht in frederick gegen das
gesetz verstoßen denn die typen im
friederici verstehen keinen spaß das hat
sich rumgesprochen
mit 300.000 dollar hat dieses
militärische ungetüm einen stolzen preis
woher hat der sheriff solche mittel
wir haben es nicht mit steuergeldern
bezahlt sondern mit gewinnen aus
beschlagnahmungen in der drogenfahndung
und aus der unterbringung von
einwanderern
für den sheriff den gewinne und
gefängnis hand in hand vor elf jahren
hat er in der strafvollzugsanstalt ein
auffanglager für illegale einwanderer
eingerichtet
pro tag zahlt der staat für jeden
bewohner dort 90 dollar mehr als doppelt
so viel wie die unterbringung
tatsächlich kostet
so verdient das gefängnis jährlich rund
1,8 millionen dollar an illegalen
einwanderern
alles kriminelle sagt sheriff jenkins
sie in den vereinigten staaten hat
probleme mit illegaler einwanderung
menschen kommen illegal in dieses land
und begehen straftaten gegen amerikaner
und gegen ihre eigenen leute das ist ein
lokales und ein nationales problem und
ich habe mich entschieden zu dessen
lösung beizutragen
eine drehgenehmigung für das
auffanglager auf dass er so stolz ist
wollte der chef allerdings nicht
erteilen bald schon wird deutlich warum
das kamerateam filmt heimlich vom gang
aus vier einwanderer
man sieht schnell das sind teenager
höchstwahrscheinlich minderjährig
jugendliche in uniform im selben
gefängnis wie erwachsene auch in den usa
ist das illegal aber im gefängnis das
sheriff ist es kein novum
dem team wird ein brief zugespielt
verfasst von der kanzlei eines
pflichtverteidigers vor einem jahr in
diesem brief wird der scherf beschuldigt
illegal minderjährige unterzubringen
das aktuelle vorgehen der
justizvollzugsanstalt frederik setzt
minderjährige gefangenen gefahren aus
und verstößt gegen das gesetz zur
verhinderung von vergewaltigung in
gefängnissen sowie gegen den achten
zusatzartikel namentlich das verbot
grausamer und unangemessene bestrafung
ein jahr später hat sich daran offenbar
nichts geändert der sheriff bringt nach
wie vor illegal minderjährige im
gefängnis des countys unter
die leute verstehen nicht warum ich
gewisse entscheidungen treffe ich liebe
amerika ich liebe dieses county und die
art und weise wie wir hier leben und ich
will nicht dass man uns das wegnimmt
[Musik]
jenkins politik zeigt wirkung seit
seiner wahl vor zwölf jahren sind
einbrüche und raubüberfälle in der stadt
um 20 prozent zurückgegangen dank seines
enormen budgets konnte er die anzahl der
polizeibeamten verdoppeln so aus wie
läuft alles klar
ein bis zweimal die woche nimmt er an
der einsatzbesprechung teil
[Musik]
danke für eure arbeit wird in diesem
county viel abverlangt ihr sollt überall
seien bei sportveranstaltungen in
schulen bei öffentlichen veranstaltungen
in der bücherei alle wollen eure dienste
aber niemand will dafür bezahlen
auf jenkins anordnung hin gibt es mehr
streifen und personenkontrollen
haben sie diebesgut im fahrzeug
und auch die anzahl der festnahmen hat
zugenommen manche verlaufen äußerst
brutal wie diese die eine
überwachungskamera eines geschäfts in
frederick festhält
[Musik]
ein mutmaßlicher drogendealer wird
zunächst zu boden geworfen dann kommt
ein beamter hinzu er schlägt den
wehrlosen mann immer wieder mit der
faust ins gesicht
insgesamt elf mal
im gefängnis von frederik dem
vorzeigeprojekt des sheriffs ist man
stolz auf den streng ruf
wir sprechen mit blake einem der
anführer der familie er steht ständig
unter genauester beobachtung aber er
versucht gelassen zu bleiben
[Musik]
sie halten mich für gefährlich aber ich
glaube das liegt nur daran dass sich
smart bin und das passt nicht in ihr
bild
trotz aller vorsichtsmaßnahmen
unterschätzt der sheriff ihn und seine
gang womöglich behauptet zumindest blake
denken sie hätten die kontrolle aber da
liegen sie falsch von wegen
wie meinen sie das
wie in jedem gefängnis gibt es hier
korruption
ein paar der wächter arbeiten für uns
ein paar auch nicht
alles eine frage des geldes
will blake sich nur vor der kamera
wichtig machen
das lässt sich nur schwer einschätzen
seine gang war in den letzten zehn
jahren in mehrere korruptionsfälle in
maryland verwickelt einige davon sind
kaum zu glauben
ein bandenchef hat heute weiter zu
korruption in einem bundesgefängnis
ausgesagt
kevin lyde anführer der bäckerei your
family hatte im gefängnis von baltimore
einen schmugglerring für alkohol drogen
und handys aufgebaut
dafür hatte er vier wach beamtinnen
bestochen
aber nicht nur mit geld
alle vier wurden von ihm schwanger
offenbar waren sie dem bed boy charme
des gangsters auf den leim gegangen
solche beziehungen kommen immer wieder
vor
[Musik]
einige wochen nach den ersten
filmaufnahmen kommt break wegen guter
führung auf bewährung frei
er lebt in einer wohnung in einem
arbeiterviertel von baltimore
der bandenführer wirkt völlig verändert
er hat sogar einen job als bauarbeiter
ich muss neu anfangen diesmal alles
legal stadt illegal
deswegen halte ich auch den ganzen
papierkram zusammen
gehaltsabrechnung und so
[Musik]
er hat auch eine neue freundin tina die
beiden haben sich kennengelernt als er
noch in haft war china hatte ihn als
sozialarbeiterin bei seiner
rehabilitation
unterstützt beziehungen zu gefangenen
sind eigentlich verboten
ja ich habe ihn kennengelernt also in
haft war das ist tatsächlich das erste
mal dass mir so was passiert ist
normalerweise würde ich nie was mit
jemandem aus dem gefängnis anfangen
das habe ich ihm auch schon oft gesagt
aber josef ist anders als jeder andere
den ich je kennengelernt habe
sie akzeptiert und versteht nicht und
sie ist da wann immer ich ihre hilfe
brauche
als seine freundin nicht mehr dabei ist
gibt der bandenführer uns gegenüber zu
dass er nicht vorhat seine verbindungen
ins kriminelle milieu zu kappen
seit seiner entlassung wird er ständig
von der polizei überwacht
regelmäßig fahren beamte in seiner
gegend streife zu blakes
bewährungsauflagen gehört täglich an
einem rehabilitationsprogramm
teilzunehmen
zu seiner sozialarbeiterin hat er ein
enges fast familiäres verhältnis
das nutzt er aus
guten morgen mama
hab dich lieb
ich dich auch willkommen dreck macht er
sich
so gut er
ist gerade erst zurück
hoffentlich hilft ihm das programmen
sich wieder in die gesellschaft zu
integrieren
eine arbeitsstelle er will auch bald
heiraten
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass er nicht wieder auf die
schiefe bahn gerät
für blake haben die termine im drogen
rehabilitationszentrum einen großen
vorteil hier darf die polizei laut
gesetz keinerlei abhörtechnik
installieren von hier aus kann er
ungestört von der polizei seine gang
kontaktieren
hier bin ich sicher von der polizei sie
können mich nicht abhören filmen oder
beobachten das wäre illegal
und so hält er von hier aus kontakt zu
seiner gang und koordiniert illegale
geschäfte vor laufender kamera kümmert
er sich um einen heiklen vorfall ein
dealer seiner gang hatte eine
auseinandersetzung mit einer
rivalisierenden bande blake gibt ihm
anweisungen
was hat er denn gesagt der typ von dem
blatt hat auf ihn geschossen und er hat
zurückgeschossen
ich sag's wie es ist da bin ich ganz
ehrlich
wenn er anfängt mist zu bauen schmeiße
ich ihn raus
was passiert ist ist passiert aber wenn
er jetzt die füße still hält hat er
meine rückendeckung
ja man keine ahnung was das soll aber
nach ihm klar dass du die hosen an hass
nicht er
macht die ansagen
blake hat wohl nicht vor zum völlig
gesetzestreuen bürger zu werden und
selbst wenn er wollte die gang würde das
kaum zu lassen es ist einer der
berüchtigsten gangs der usa sie ist
jedes jahr in mehr als 100 mordfälle
verwickelt
glaubst du wirst wieder in haft kommen
[Musik]
nein ich lasse mich nicht mehr erwischen
nächstes mal müssen sie mich umbringen
ich gehe nicht zurück
[Musik]
zurück im frauen trakt im gefängnis von
jarratt
esche und ihre tochter haben mit ihrer
kriminellen vergangenheit abgeschlossen
sie hoffen vorzeitig entlassen zu werden
wie blake
hier nehmen wir flaggen hier in der
kleinen fabrik verdiente natascha
monatlich 120 dollar sie näht flatten
für die us-regierung ironie des
gefängnis lebens ich muss inventur
machen
sind ja
wie viele musst du machen eine
nur eine
ist die andere kaputt nein ich glaube
die gegner
hier dürfen nur bestimmte gefangene
arbeiten
mit manchen straftaten geht das nicht
weil wir gefährliche werkzeuge benutzen
wenn du hier arbeitest dann wissen die
leute dass du dich geändert hast
dass du an dir arbeitest
natascha hofft wegen ihrer vorbildlichen
führung gleichzeitig mit ihrer tochter
entlassen zu werden die eine kürzere
haftstrafe absitzt
ich arbeite hart um geld zu sparen
sie wird irgendwann in den nächsten drei
wochen entlassen
draußen haben wir nicht allzu viele
leute die uns helfen werden
sie wird auch hart arbeiten müssen
wir geben beide alles damit sie bereit
für ihre entlassung und die welt da
draußen ist
natascha ist optimistisch denn sie hat
gerüchte gehört
die anwalt sagt dass sie gute chancen
auf eine vorzeitige entlassung hat
[Musik]
nach der arbeit ist der tasche wieder
ganz mutter
[Musik]
chanel hat zwei jahre lang spanisch
gelernt um den abschluss in
internationaler wirtschaft zu machen
ihre mutter unterstützt sie bei den
hausaufgaben wer das geschrieben
das hast du geschrieben am computer ok
ich
hab' den spanischkurs auch belegt ich
versuche ihr zu helfen wo ich kann
sie ist sehr klug sie holt schnell auf
bald muss sie mir helfen
die frauen wissen dass richter
nachsichtiger mit gefangenen sind die
sich fortbilden kammer hat die echte
arbeitswelt noch nie kennengelernt sie
ist in der gittern erwachsen geworden
wird sie sich draußen zurechtfinden
[Musik]
es wird schwer für sie
weil sie aus der haft kommt
und zweitens weil sie zehn mal härter
wird arbeiten müssen
es ist schon schwierig für frauen gute
jobs zu bekommen auch alte noch für mich
wird es noch schwieriger aber ich packte
sie geht nicht wieder in haft nein
wir müssen vorsichtig sein
aber darauf sind wir vorbereitet
in drei wochen werden sie erfahren wie
es weitergeht dann gibt der richter die
entscheidung über ihren
entlassungsantrag bekannt
scherf jenkins und seine wähler wünschen
sich solche muster gefangenen die sich
gut führen und nach ihrer entlassung
nicht wieder straffällig werden
alles in ordnung ich habe sie immer im
radio ach ja ja sind sie meiner meinung
des bin ich sehr gut
diesem sonntag tritt er bei einem ganz
speziellen bingo abend auf wie es ihn
wohl nur in den usa gibt
guten abend zusammen willkommen allen
früh ankömmling dann wollen wir mal ein
bisschen geld locker machen
diese bingo winden nicht die typischen
gewinne wie urlaubsreisen oder fernseher
in maryland sind die begehrtesten preise
gewehre und schrotflinten
[Musik]
das kann man überall gebrauchen für die
jagd in der wildnis überall in
nordamerika
das wertvollste ist das remis 700
das dürfte das teuerste hier sein liegt
so bei 900 dollar
die beliebte veranstaltung lockt jedes
jahr mehr als 600 teilnehmer an jäger
familien sogar jugendliche
es ist das konservative amerika
eine der teilnehmerinnen ist michelle
sie ist mutter und jägerin und lässt
sich die veranstaltung nur selten
entgehen
es hat sich nur so ergeben war ein paar
jungs von der arbeit gewettet haben ich
könnte kein wild schießen ohne zu weinen
ich wollte ihnen das gegenteil beweisen
also habe ich den schein gemacht und
zwei hirsche geschossen
das ist sehr friedlich und echt
entspannt
letztes jahr hat michelle einen gewinn
abgeräumt daher spielt sie dieses jahr
nicht für sich selbst
mein sohn will ein camouflage gewähr
wenn ich gewinne kriegt er das hier
ein gewehr oder einen 350 dollar
einkaufsgutschein gewinnt die
neben ihrer liebe zu waffen teilen diese
amerikaner eine tiefe bewunderung für
ihren chef
er beschützt familien das land und das
county
ja er macht einen super job
er kümmert sich um gesetzestreue
anständige bürger wir uns toll dass er
herkommt und hier mitmacht
jenkins ist ein guter mann er steht für
das woran wir glauben diese amerikaner
haben eine klare vision für irland und
zwar ohne unerwünschte zuwanderer wer
nicht legal hier ist wird abgeschoben
keine mauer wäre wirklich super mehr sag
ich nicht vor der kamera aber das wäre
super
einer der eifrigsten unterstützer des
schiffs ist sein sohn hier fällt der
apfel tatsächlich nicht weit vom stamm
er ist gerade polizist geworden
menschen zu helfen ist eine tolle
aufgabe man ist unterwegs kommt mit
leuten ins gespräch und versucht was zu
bewirken
das blaue ticket mit der nummer 100
gewinnt das ist michelles nummer
gelangen
glückwunsch danke ich dachte schon die
100 gelingt nicht
vielen dank für ihren dienst am land
jahr ihre mühe einen grossen applaus
das ist die heile welt wie sie sich
scharf jenkins vorstellt es ist eine
heile welt nur für einen kleinen teil
der amerikaner
nach abschluss der dreharbeiten haben
eine tasche und sharm el- die
entscheidung des richters bekommen
ihr antrag auf vorzeitige entlassung
wurde abgelehnt
erst in einigen jahren dürfen sie es
wieder versuchen
blake und tina haben geheiratet aus
einer gang ist blake jedoch nicht
ausgestiegen bisher ist er polizeilich
nicht auffällig geworden aber wie lange
wird das so bleiben
in maryland landet einer von zwei aus
dem gefängnis entlassenen später wieder
im knast eine statistik die chef
schenkens lieber ignoriert seine
beliebtheit steigt von jahr zu jahr
er hofft bald als gouverneur zu
kandidieren
[Musik]